let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go okay I got to put my jacket
on hey guys what is happening on my
phone over here this group chat is going
wild so right now Jenna and I are on to
a little Adventure are you ready Jenna
oh yeah ready today on the docket we're
going to Best Buy to visit the Intel
experience we're going to go to get a I
really want to get a smoothie please let
me get a smoothie Jenna doesn't want to
go because it's in the opposite
direction of where we need to go there's
traffic we got to take him to the vet
because he's been having a little cough
recently and we're not sure what's
happening and he gained 2 lb he did gain
2 lb do you guys want to guess what
tripod we're using right
now dog food also going to be getting a
little item to unbox for Tech Tuesday
kind of excited about it it's been out
for a little while
but I held back I didn't get it but now
I am so it defeats the purpose let's go
wait you're not going I got to put you
in your
cage
he's going for the bait okay we'll be
back soon love
you Jenna is so excited about our trip
today I called I was like Jen let's roll
and then she was stuck in traffic you
have never called anyone ever on the
phone it's funny cuz I was thinking
about the last Vlog that we were doing
we went and got juice and then also went
to Best Buy and I went to lunch and did
the same exact thing we did I was
thinking that too cuz I was like I'm
going to Vlog today like this is going
to look just like the Vlog from a couple
weeks ago where do I park that looks
good
[Music]
gosh do you remember the song ooh I'm at
the Best Buy oh my God your song yes I
doo my
song he's cleaning himself very
inappropriate all right with here Intel
experience they've got a couple new
things since the last time we were here
what's this I don't know let's do our
first demo this is plug into your
imagination let me tell you my
imagination it's the best how to play
touch the screen s the game Connect tap
the connected
objects our next demo is I by power PC
here at the Intel experience let's
play God I'm so
good all right what do we got next this
is pretty cool they have real-time
statistics now I got an actual live demo
of this at one of the Intel events and
they had them on BMX bikes but here
they're putting them on
snowboards that's crazy so you basically
can say oh are you doing a I don't know
any snowboard terms are you doing a
insert snowboard term trick here yes you
are here's how fast you were going all
the info create a new video
project watch my video
uh did you see what I just did Jenna you
made that I edit this video I just made
by touching like five things this would
take me like four or five
hours it's called Fast cut appropriate
name I don't think it could even be more
appropriate all right we've got some
laptops here all using Intel processors
of course I like that there's like so
many different options it's like do you
want a little baby
do you want a bigger baby or do you want
a real big baby I like that this has the
WD Keys already outlined I feel like
most Gamers know where those keys are
though these are the type of exercises
that I do before I play video games all
right let's check this one out this is
always my favorite the last time we were
here I think they made like a movie
trailer but this time it's like this
huge massive display it's called the
food truck challenge so this is pretty
cool this demo here shows you sort of
the two in one technology basically you
can turn your laptops into a tablet you
can flip the screens around and do cool
things just like this here's one way you
can use the laptop and here's another
way tap or flick chicken on the grill I
just I just flicked the chicken on the
grill okay she wants a cola how do I
make a drink oh my God over here fill
the
cup
oh come on I I didn't I didn't cook the
meat I didn't cook the meat
[Music]
properly what I thought they walked away
I didn't I didn't know I did it actually
never seen this before revolutionary
athletic eyewear that lets you easily
see data about your performance in real
time and the basis Peak I had one of the
old basis watches I absolutely love
being able to quantify what I did if I
do a workout I want to know how many
steps I took how many calories I
[Music]
burned it doesn't look like I'm a high
score they how many did you get
34 I might need to practice a little all
right that concludes our little Intel
experience demo here let me know if you
guys have been to the Intel experience
in your Best Buy now we need to get the
item for a tech Tuesday unbox in this
way do you know what the item is yes
okay you told me you guys will find out
later all right we've got our secret
item in front of me I'm super excited to
unbox it for next week but now D where
we going we can we please get a smoothie
a Smoothie Please the secret item the
secret item the secret item all right
let's get in the car the car is not over
there okay you guys look good where is
it across from Blue Plate nope not a
spot like it's right there I'm going to
stay in the car if you put your head
hazards on it's not illegal I'm a liar I
think you are okay hurry give me okay
give me the finest juice I'm not going
to take this in I'll leave this here did
you take that yeah your battery's going
to die it's almost like fall W let's get
out of here we got the
[Music]
Smoothie
M this feel good today oh seat belt save
you first oh look at this he's like no
I'll play with this he loves this blank
pillow thing MADD this smells like you
well he rubs his body on
it where's piggy puppet I actually I
actually don't know I don't either
Maddie has one tooth that is bigger than
the other it's really sad I think I need
a nap before I take him to the vet oh
gosh Maddie do you want to come nap with
me come on M get up here up up
hey come back over here honey
oh I can't reach my phone Maddie who do
you want to go with your mommy or me do
you want to come over here to me Maddie
come here come here butd maybe I have
something for you what do you have for
him
[Music]
love
hi Maddie are you ready to go to the
vet look at you so we're now at the vet
I hope he's okay he just has like these
weird coughs so I just wanted to bring
him to make
sure good morning it's next day thought
I would update you guys on madd's little
vet appointment
look at you just waiting for
[Music]
me they W really sure but they started
him on some antibiotics they think his
little throat might be
inflamed my office is a mess as usual
about to finish editing some Vlogs for
you guys so that's going to be the day
like really slob what do you want you
want your bone there you go get it guess
he doesn't want his bone look at that
she brought all kinds of toys to play
with thank you guys for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this video I've got
nothing else to say and I will guess
I'll see you in the next one
bye what's in the box what could be in
the Box